à l'hôpital d'auxerre les patients ne
parle que de ça les comptes sont dans le
rouge et l'établissement pourrait fermer
des lits pour faire des économies mais
pas question d'aller à dijon ou à paris
pour se faire soigner c'est pas facile
parce que les gens qui n'ont pas le
permis ou les personnes âgées où on
pourra par on est finie dans l'yonne
parce que y'a plus rien à bâle on s'en
fout avec bientôt avoir un hélicoptère
pour la l'hôpital c'est pas normal de
fermer des lits il faudrait qu'ils ans
rouvre même parce que c'est ce qu'ils
demandent que ça va mal finir la date un
travail à derry grève la grève
ces représentants du personnel s'y
prépare déjà une cinquantaine de lits
pourrait fermer soit l'équivalent de
deux services avec des conséquences pour
les usagers comme pour le personnel à
partir du monde on diminue l'accueil du
patient en réduisant l'offre de soins
donc ils service ça va impliquer qu'il y
aura une baisse d'activité encore et
encore
et puis au niveau du personnel ça veut
dire qu'on ya une mobilité un petit peu
contrainte et forcée mais très personnel
dans l'établissement si peu partout 26
millions d'euros le montant du déficit
cumulé de l'hôpital ces dernières années
c'est 15% du budget total de
fonctionnement
pour la direction il est vital de
revenir à un équilibre mais sans
détériorer et demi l'offre de soins sur
l'ensemble des activités on a toujours
les activités qu'on fait aujourd'hui qui
se feront demain seulement il faudra les
adapter à l'évolution aussi de ce qu'on
constate partout c'est à dire
l'émergence qui se tarde un peu plus à
se mettre en place dans notre hôpital de
l'ambulatoire par rapport à
l'hospitalisation complète pour réaliser
les économies demandées par la tutelle
l'hôpital d'auxerre va développer la
médecine ambulatoire
les premières mesures seront connues en
novembre les syndicats eux appellent à
se mobiliser contre la fermeture
annoncée de lit